Speaker 1: We've had a lot of these different
stories of casually anti-vaccine people
dying of COVID, and these are stories that are
very controversial within even my audience about
should we feel sympathy? Should we feel glee?
Should we feel both? Should we feel neither or
whatever the case may be? We now have a story of
a very well-known longtime anti-vaccine leader who
has died of COVID. This is an Italian individual
named Luigi Morelli. All of the articles about
him, almost all of the articles that I found are
in Italian. So we're looking at a translation on
Reddit about this. And as the story goes. Luigi
Morelli, 63, the leader of the No Vax Movement in
Abruzzo, died after suffering from COVID. Remember
that there is a significant anti-vaccine movement
in Italy. Italy has we talked about this predating
COVID when it came to measles? A big problem in
parts of Italy. The activist died in the hospital
where he was hospitalized. He was the territorial
representative for his region of liberty, amo
Alitalia, and was among the first to fight the war
against vaccines and the Green Pass obligation.
He had been living in Abruzzo for some time,
was always in the front line, chaired all the
main protest events in the sit in the streets
in recent months. This is a Google translation.
That's why the syntax is sort of weird.
The protest comrades gave the news of their
leader's death on Facebook without ever mentioning
the cause. News like that of the death of our
beloved Luigi Merilee, a member of the National
Direction of Liberty Army Alitalia, one of the
founders of the Liberation March and spokesman
they write in a note. Are those that would
never want to receive his strength of mind
testified by the tireless activity of guiding and
coordinating the Abruzzo Committee and the other
resistance forces came from the certainty
and pride of always fighting for justice,
equality, freedom. It never mentions what actually
happened. And if you scroll through the comments,
you see a post from his friend Marino Ricchiuti,
who says he died of COVID. He died of COVID.
This is not a joke, guys. This is a very
serious situation and you have not only casually
anti-vaccine people like the right wing radio host
who is like, Yeah, I'm not getting vaccinated,
I don't need that. And then they get sick and then
they die. This is a long time anti-vaccine leader.
Now, does it make it more tragic that this was
an anti-vaccine leader? No, it doesn't make it
more tragic, but it should just serve as a stark
reminder that your opinions really don't matter.
We've got a bell curve, and there are a lot
of people in the middle of that bell curve
who will sort of get a little sick and then
recover. And then you've got people at one
end of the bell curve who just will never get
it, even despite multiple exposures or they'll
be asymptomatic. And then on the other side of
the bell curve, you've got people who are going
to die from this, and they might be anti-vax as
a career like this guy. And it doesn't matter.
It's not something I point and laugh at, but we
should remember that for all of these different
groups that spread the disinformation, it's
not only the unvaccinated that are dying.
It's the anti-vax activists that are dying as
well. This was a well-known guy who was known
in the anti-vax community of Italy, and he has
now died of COVID. We'll have more on this on
our Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show. We'll take a quick break and be right back.